- Since this is a 1980s
movie about frat brothers,
there has to be a scene about dudes
getting it on with an animal.
(sheep bleats)
I don't know how we're going
to be able to release this
on YouTube, oh my God.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back to Laws Broken,
the series where a real lawyer pulverizes
your pleasant movies from the 1980s
by showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal.
I'm sure most of you have probably watched
Revenge of the Nerds
at one time or another.
Well specifically you probably watched it
at three o'clock in the morning on TBS
since that's the only time slot
where eighties frat boy
comedies were allowed to air,
albeit in highly edited form,
and you might not remember all
of the laws that were broken
in Revenge of the Nerds, but I assure you,
there were a lot of them
because the main fixation
of these type of movies
is of course, girls.
- There's 6,127 Students at Adams,
58% of which are girls.
- So?
- So that's 7,107.32 boobs.
- [Devin] And thankfully,
we've come a long time
since this movie was released.
Yes, Revenge of the Nerds
is from another era,
before nerds were celebrated,
part of the zeitgeists
and they had their own
award-winning TV shows.
- Sarcasm.
- You think?
- But in 1984, people
were not so sensitive
to the plight of the nerds.
Hence, we got Revenge of the Nerds,
a movie about a group
of criminal degenerates
and their plea for tolerance.
So the criming kicks off with
what may be an actual murder.
As Lewis and Gilbert, the lead nerds,
walk through their Adams
College for the first time,
they walked right by the
alpha beta fraternity.
This sets up what is
probably the most quoted line
from the movie.
- Nerds!
- Ogre! Ogre! Ogre!
- Yes, Ogre takes one look at
the pair of computer junkies
and lets out a primal roar, as one does.
This sets Lewis and Gilbert on edge,
as they realized that they are
subjects of intense derision.
What they don't seem to notice is
that Ogre is dangling a man from the roof
and that man then presumably
drops 30 or more feet
to the ground.
Did he die?
Did he just break his neck?
Did we just watch a murder take place
in the first five minutes of this movie?
Well, the movie takes
place at Adams College,
a fictional college
somewhere in the Midwest.
Since I've never picked
on Nebraska before,
let's pick on Nebraska.
I'm setting the movie
smack dab in the middle
of the corn husker state, and in Nebraska,
a person commits murder
in the first degree
if he or she kills another person,
one, purposely and with
deliberate and premeditated murder
or two, in the perpetration
or the attempt to perpetrate
any other first degree felony.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
that there just aren't many
circumstances that justify
intentionally dangling
a person off of a roof.
First degree murder carries
a potential life sentence
if the person dies, but if
there's just an attempt,
then it's a class two felony,
which carries a penalty of
up to 50 years in prison.
I think Ogre is probably
going to get out in 25
with good behavior.
Now the plot, so to
speak, really takes off
when the alphas accidentally burn down
their fraternity house.
In their defense, who knew
that playing with a Zippo
and drinking 180 proof whiskey
could lead to an actual fire?
So is this arson?
Well, probably not.
A person only commits first degree arson
if they intentionally
set fire to a structure
or start a fire while in the process
of committing another felony.
The firestarter here appears
to be a guy named Haystack.
I guess that explains this
movie's choice to put him
in overalls.
But at any rate he didn't
intentionally set the fire.
Accident is generally a defense to arson,
but he might also be able
to plead diminished capacity
because of extreme intoxication.
Now, intoxication is another version
of a diminished capacity defense.
Involuntary intoxication
is when someone drugs you,
or you take something that
you didn't expect to react to,
but voluntary intoxication
is when you really do mean
to get drunk, and of course you succeed.
Now getting drunk on purpose
is not a defense on its own,
otherwise we'd all get
drunk and commit crimes
without consequence.
However, if you're so wasted
that you can't control your actions,
then it might mean the
prosecutors would have a hard time
proving that you set
the fire intentionally.
So based on these defenses,
it might be the Haystack
is safe from charges
of first degree arson.
But that doesn't mean that everyone
is completely off the hook.
The guys tell the fire department
that the fire was caused
by some faulty wiring.
This is probably a misstep.
It's definitely a crime to lie
to law enforcement authorities.
Nebraska law calls these false reporting,
quote, a person commits an
offense of false reporting
if he or she, a, furnishes
material information
he or she knows to be
false to any peace officer
or other official with the intent
to instigate an investigation
of an alleged criminal matter
or to impede the investigation
of an actual criminal matter.
This is a class one misdemeanor.
Now the alpha betas face
up to one year in jail
and/or a thousand dollar
fine for false reporting.
But shout out to a young John
Goodman as the football coach
who helps the guys get
alternative housing,
and there is of course
a big game coming up
and he doesn't want them worrying about
where they're going to live.
The Dean acquiesces to this plan,
which then leads to the
next scenes where the alphas
are storming the freshmen dormitory
and throwing everyone out.
- So as of now that dorm is ours, right?
- Yeah!
- Any room you want, ready?
- Ready!
- [Devin] These guys are
probably the same ones
that 35 years later
would storm the Capitol
and basically do the same thing.
Ogre then throws a man out the window.
Now, just because the
Dean consented to the plan
doesn't mean that the way
that they moved into the dorms
was legal.
Throwing a guy out the window
is still assault and battery,
and more precisely it's defenestration.
Defenestration is one of my favorite words
in the English language.
It's the act of throwing
someone out a window.
Now in the past, defenestration
has ignited multiple wars,
including the Bohemian Revolt
against the Habsburg emperor
Ferdinand II, which started
the 30 years war back in 1618.
Now here in America
defenestration is usually
just considered aggravated battery.
Charles Barkley once famously heaved a man
through a glass window after
the man harassed several people
at a bar.
Barkley said what he
did was inappropriate.
I'm going to defend myself.
Let there be no debate, if you bother me,
I'm going to whip your ass.
The guy threw ice in my face
and I slammed his ass into the window.
Let it never be said that Charles Barkley
doesn't have a way with words.
Now Barkley was charged
with aggravated battery,
but the case was dropped after the man
who got thrown through the
window declined to prosecute.
That happened after he signed
a settlement with Sir Charles.
Now in Nebraska, the state
charges this as an assault crime
quote, a person commits
the offense of assault
in the first degree, if he or
she intentionally or knowingly
causes serious bodily
injury to another person.
First degree assault
is a class two felony.
Class two felonies carry
you possible punishment
of up to 50 years in prison,
but I think the outcome
here depends a lot on
whether the victim was seriously
hurt or just banged up.
Ogre probably got first degree assault.
Yeah, let's say 10 years, but
let's focus now on the nerds.
The nerds are now homeless
and seeking a fraternity.
So Betty Childs, the
leader of the mean girls,
intervenes to send them
to the alpha betas,
where they will be humiliated.
- Well, tell us what
frat do you think is us?
- You guys are alpha betas all the way.
- [Devin] Since this is a 1980s
movie about frat brothers,
there has to be a scene
about dudes getting it on
with an animal.
Here is that scene.
- You guys seem pretty cool.
Take these for later.
- Rubbers? What do we need rubbers for?
(sheep bleats)
- Okay, that is more than
enough of that scene.
We don't actually see Gilbert and Lewis
fornicating with the sheep,
but if they did, that is
the crime of indecency
with an animal quote,
a person commits indecency with an animal
when such person subjects an
animal to sexual penetration
as defined in section 28-318.
Lewis and Gilbert, therefore
indecency with an animal
as a class three misdemeanor,
get up to three months in
jail and/or a $500 fine.
Now in our next scene, it
features multiple instances
of the cinema sin of racial stereotyping,
where a frat bro asked
Takashi if he knows karate,
and then he puts a jockstrap on his head.
- You know karate?
- No.
- Good.
- Now under Nebraska law in 1984,
this is simple assault at best.
Misdemeanor assault is
assault in the third degree
and consists of either
intentionally, knowingly,
or recklessly causing bodily
injury to another person
or threatening another
in a menacing manner.
Now Takashi isn't seriously hurt
so this isn't a felony case,
but 21st century bullies beware,
because in 1997, Nebraska
passed a hate crimes law
that enhances criminal penalties
when a person commits an offense
because of someone's race,
color, religion, ancestry,
national origin, gender,
sexual orientation, age, or disability.
If found guilty of a
hate crime under the law
it acts as a penalty enhancement.
This means that a person will be punished
for the next level of offense.
So if you were to use a racial slur
or ask a guy if he knows
karate before choking him
with his own jock strap,
expect prosecutors to consider
a penalty enhancement.
So random frat guy,
the penalty in this case would
be up to six months in jail,
a fine of up to $1,000, or both.
Luckily for this guy, cancel
culture hasn't arrived in 1984
so this guy can probably
just get off with probation.
Now in the next scene,
Lewis inadvertently invents
apartments.com, Zillow, and Airbnb.
- [Lewis] Okay I've programmed
him with all the rental units
in the area.
- And the computer he
built looks totally like
it's related to the dogs.
You don't see it?
Well, just wait until you
see it in action later on.
- Now, Lewis's Zillow mode
brings us to this scene
where Wormser, the 13 year old,
goes to one of the apartments
and is hit on by an adult woman.
- Hi, I came about the room for rent.
- That's right next to mine.
It'll be perfect for us.
- [Devin] Why yes, she did answer the door
wearing a negligee and she
immediately offers the boy sex,
things that would only
happen in a 1980s frat movie.
Now this is criminal child enticement.
Quote, no person by any means
and without privilege to
do so, shall solicit, coax,
entice, or lure or attempt to
solicit, coax, entice, or lure
any child under the age
of 14 years into any place
with the intent to seclude the child
from his or her parent,
guardian, or the legal custodian
or the general public,
whether or not the person
knows the age of the child.
The perspective landlady,
arguably tried to entice
Wormser into the house
in violation of law.
She's guilty of a class 3A felony.
Class 3A felonies carry
a possible punishment
of up to three years in prison,
and an 18 month post release supervision
and/or up to a $10,000 fine.
And is it also contributing
to the delinquency of a child?
Well, under section 28-709 of
the Nebraska criminal code,
any person who by any
act encourages, causes,
or contributes to the delinquency
or need for special supervision of a child
under 18 years of age,
so the child becomes,
or will tend to become a delinquent child
or a child in need of special supervision
commits contributing to
the delinquency of a child.
Now there's a lot of gray
area about what it means
for a child to quote,
tend to become delinquent.
Wormser isn't a child in
need of special supervision.
In fact, he's actually a genius,
but the statute doesn't require
that the child actually become delinquent
or need special supervision,
but only that the defendant
encouraged the child
to become delinquent or to
need special supervision
so that the child will quote,
tend to become a delinquent child
or a child in need of special supervision.
So let's say this landlady
is getting slapped
with six months in jail for her
tendency to create a delinquent child.
And then of course, the
computer that he created
basically goes off and
becomes (indistinct)
even attacking a human being.
Now, when the newly-minted
Tri-Lambs plan a party,
they struggled to get dates,
and this is where the movie takes a turn
from Revenge of the Nerds
into Revenge of the Incels.
Of course, Booger has
been searching for dates
at the local high school.
- Have any of you guys
got dates besides Gilbert?
- I do.
- Yeah, but that's with a guy.
- What about you Booger?
- I've been out combing
the high schools all day.
- [Devin] And although
we don't see his conduct,
if we take him at his word,
he has potentially broken several laws.
First is stalking, which
is defined as being
willfully harassed, intentionally
terrified, threatened,
or intimidated by individuals
who intentionally follow,
detain, stalk, or harass them.
Harassing behavior occurs when
someone engages in conduct
that quote seriously terrifies,
threatens, or intimidates
the person and which serves
no legitimate purpose.
This is a class one misdemeanor,
unless the victim is under 16 years old
when it becomes a felony.
So Booger is almost certainly
facing up to a year in jail
and/or a thousand dollar fine just for
stalking these teen girls.
Now, after the frat
boys and girls continued
to mock the nerds, the
nerds formulate a plan.
For revenge, the nerds
decided not to commit violence
against the alphas
because that would only bring
them down to their level
so instead they decide to commit
violence against the women.
- I know what we're gonna do.
- [Devin] Or in this movie's parlance,
they decide to have a fun panty raid.
These are the protagonists
of this movie, remember.
So let me give you a
rundown of all the crimes
in this particular scene.
First there's burglary.
A person commits burglary
if such person willfully,
maliciously, or forcibly breaks
and enters any real estate
or any improvements erected thereon
with the intent to commit any felony.
The men broke in with the intent
of chasing down naked women
and planting video
cameras on the premises.
I think that probably
qualifies as having the intent
to commit a felony.
Now in Nebraska, burglary
can be charged as either
a class two or class three felony,
depending on the
circumstances of the case.
Class two felony in Nebraska is punishable
by up to 50 years in prison,
while a class three felony is punishable
by up to four years in prison.
So let's pretty much just
throw the book at Lewis
and give him 50 years in
prison for committing burglary
in order to commit a
whole bunch of sex crimes.
Then of course there is the guilt
of first degree criminal trespass.
A person commits first
degree criminal trespass
if he or she quote,
enters or secretly remains
in any building or occupied structure
or any separately secured
or occupied portion thereof,
knowing that he or she is not licensed
or privileged to do so.
This is a first degree misdemeanor
that probably will not carry more than
three to six months in jail.
And then the here's Lewis,
terrifyingly just hiding in the shower,
then jumping out, yelling panty raid,
and then chasing the
naked girls down the hall.
- Panty raid!
(woman screams)
- [Devin] Today, this would have ended
with Olivia Benson
taking the perp to jail,
but in 1984, it was played for laughs.
But Lewis may be guilty of
second or third degree
sexual assault, quote,
any person who subjects
another to sexual contact
without consent of the victim
is guilty of sexual assault
in either the second or third degree.
And what is sexual contact?
You probably didn't ask.
Well, that is defined as
the intentional touching
of the victim's sexual or intimate parts
or the intentional touching
of the victim's clothing
covering the immediate area
of the victim's sexual or intimate parts.
Now, unfortunately for the victims here,
sexual assault is only
a class one misdemeanor
if the perpetrator didn't
cause serious personal injury.
Now did Lewis touch any of these women?
We don't know, but clearly
he was attempting to do that.
Third degree sexual assault
is a class one misdemeanor,
which carries a possible
penalty up to one year in jail
and a fine of $1,000,
and while the girls screamed,
the nerds congratulate
themselves on their crimes.
The nerds then install video
cameras in the sorority house
and then do terrible
things with that tape.
This is behavior that nowadays
would have gotten them
labeled as sex offenders for life,
but it's definitely an
invasion of privacy.
So what laws do they break in addition to
breaking and entering,
sexual assault, and trespass?
Well under Nebraska criminal
section 28-311, quote,
it shall be unlawful for any person
to knowingly intrude upon any other person
without his or her consent
in a place of solitude
or seclusion.
Now that's a misdemeanor,
but they also violated section two,
which states it shall be
unlawful for any person
to knowingly and intentionally
photograph, film,
or otherwise record an image
or video of an intimate area
of another person without his
or her knowledge and consent.
This is a class four felony.
The maximum penalty is
two years imprisonment
and two months post release supervision,
and a $10,000 fine, or both.
So all of them, including
the 13 year old Wormser,
are looking at a two year prison sentence
for unlawful intrusion,
and of course later they
violate section three
of that criminal code by selling
photographs of naked women,
quote, it shall be unlawful for any person
to knowingly and intentionally distribute
or otherwise make public an
image or video of another person
recorded in violation of
section two of this section
without that person's consent.
This is a class 2A felony with a 20 year
maximum prison sentence, and
when this movie was released,
there was no sex offender
registry, but today,
if the men were over 19 and any victim was
under the age of 18, they'd
be required to register
under the Sex Offender Registration Act.
And they also allow
the 13 year old Wormser
to watch these videos,
which probably contributed to
the endangerment of a minor,
and please know that the girls
were fighting off the nerds,
and this is mostly in self-defense.
Under today's laws, under
most states these days,
they probably would have been justified
in just shooting these guys
dead for home invasion.
And then finally capping off
the biggest crimes we have
that time that Lewis (beep) Betty.
Yeah, you heard me.
Lewis puts on a Darth Vader
mask, impersonates Stan,
and has sex with Stan's girlfriend, Betty.
Now sex through deception is (beep),
but it's not always punishable as a crime
depending on how the
jurisdiction defines consent.
(beep) by fraud was first recognized in
American criminal law in 1865 in Michigan,
in the People v. Croswell.
There, the Michigan Supreme Court upheld
the defendant's conviction
for (beep) by fraud
and stated quote, the
outrage upon the woman
is just as great in these
cases as if actual force
had been employed.
That's because the women didn't consent
to sex with that particular man,
which is the same situation we have here.
And of course there
always going to be people
defending the scene by
alleging that in 1984,
no one knew it was wrong,
but that's kind of like saying
that in the 18th century,
no one knew that slavery was wrong.
Definitely people knew.
In fact it was a crime back
then, so it's hard to say
that everything was hunky-dory back then,
and here to add insult to injury,
Betty is actually happy with the deception
and leaves Stan for Lewis.
- That was wonderful.
He did things to me
you've never done before.
- [Devin] And critics at the time
didn't even seem to be bothered by this.
Gene Siskell loved it.
He called the characterization
of the two "sweet"
and although Roger Ebert
listed the panty raid scene
as one part of the movie
that could put the boys
in a bad light, he called the movie great
because of the human element.
- There's a human element
underlying this film
that makes it interesting.
The story of these, of these nerds.
- I don't know how we're going to be able
to release this on YouTube, oh my God.
(upbeat jingle)
And here's a quick
rundown of the minor laws
broken in this movie.
The football team assaults Gilbert.
The coach participates, even
threatening to break his neck,
attempted assault.
Here the frat guys mooned the Tri-Lambs.
This is public indecency.
The person commits public indecency
if such person exposes, quote
the genitals of the body
done with the intent to
affront or alarm any person.
It's a class two misdemeanor,
and that would get these guys up to
six months in jail and a fine.
The frat bros and frat
girls steal a farm truck
and then turn the pigs
loose on the nerds' house.
That's simple theft and vandalism,
punishable by up to a year in jail.
The jocks placed a burning
nerd sign in front of the lawn,
vandalism, three to six months in jail.
The nerds drip some heat rub
oil on the Alpha's jockstraps.
Is that a crime?
You bet it is.
That's assault.
And let's talk about the prison sentences
for the two worst
characters in this movie.
It was written with only
one main bad guy Ogre,
but Lewis is also just
as bad, if not worse.
Ogre probably gets 25 years
in jail for attempted murder
and 15 for defenestration,
that's 40 years in jail.
And the ultimate perp
of this movie, Lewis,
will probably go to prison
for (beep) by deception.
Let's say 20 years for that.
He's also guilty of two
counts of unlawful intrusion
for entering and helping with filming,
which is four more years.
And to that 50 years for burglary,
one year for assaulting
the girls in the hallway,
his total sentence is probably
somewhere around 60 to 75 years.
Now this video isn't over.
As you can imagine,
there were a lot more crimes
that the nerds committed,
but it's too hot slash
disgusting to go on YouTube,
but you can watch the extended
version over on Nebula.
And I'm thrilled to announce
my first Nebula Original,
Bad Law Words Good.
It's a long form documentary
where I explore all the most common legal
and linguistic ideas
that people throw around
in everyday life incorrectly.
So strap in because it's
going to get really pedantic.
It's a hilarious romp through
legal misunderstandings,
logical fallacies, and
law and order parodies,
and it's only available on Nebula
because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment
with content and do things that
we couldn't put on YouTube.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with CuriosityStream
because they are the go-to
source for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire
section devoted to
unsolved mysteries and crime
so if you like my videos,
you will love the stuff
on CuriosityStream,
and we've worked out a deal where
if you sign up for CuriosityStream
with the link in the description,
you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free,
and to be clear that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as
you're a CuriosityStream member
and right now CuriosityStream
is offering 26% off
their annual plans.
That's less than $15 for
the entire year for both
CuriosityStream and Nebula.
So if you click on the link
that's onscreen right now,
you'll get CuriosityStream
and Nebula for 26% off,
or you can go to
curiositystream.com/LegalEagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content
directly for under $15 per year.
So if you want a huge
discount on CuriosityStream
and Nebula, just click on the link
that's onscreen right now
or the link that's in the description.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there
and click on this playlist
with all of my other Laws
Broken and Legal Reactions,
so click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.